contrairement à toute attente l'aviation
ukrainienne vole encore et infligent des
pertes à l'envahisseur russe mais elle
réclame de l'aide yaka sinon tit b spec
c'est pourquoi le président volodymyr
ellis qui réclame sans répit à défaut
d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne des
avions des avions des tanks et des armes
anti missile malgré cette infériorité
cet ancien aviateur militaires français
près dit ceci il ya une certitude qui
s'installe et les russes ne peuvent plus
gagner la guerre
pourquoi parce que d'abord les russes de
façon surprenante n'ont toujours pas la
maîtrise de l'air puisque les sukhoï
ukrainien volts encore évidemment il ya
cette capacité de l'aviation a continué
à voler mais il ya également une défense
aérienne qui était très bien fournie
avant la guerre il avait certainement
entre 150 et 200 systèmes de haute
altitude des systèmes book des systèmes
s-300 cela il ya une grande partie qui
est encore opérationnel et c'est pour ça
qu'on voit encore aujourd'hui par
exemple un sukhoi 30 russe qui a été
abattu
là où les occidentaux ne lésine pas ce
sens sur les lance-missiles comme le
jazz l'hymne américain il coûte moins de
cent mille dollars et envoie des
missiles par guidage thermiques capables
de percer n'importe quel blindage les
américains en ont envoyé plus de 4000 ça
s'accroche à l'infrarouge par exemple
sur les hélicoptères et c'est pour ça
que la russie a perdu plusieurs dizaines
d'hélicoptères certains n'ont plus de 40
parce que ces systèmes sont faciles à
utiliser et qu'on les a fournis en très
grande quantité et l'autre avantage
également c'est que les russes manquant
de munitions de précision ils sont
obligés de faire voler leurs avions en
très basse altitude et justement ils
descendent avec d'études à laquelle ils
sont à portée de ses missiles tirés
depuis les pôles qui sont très très
simple pour les convois et les blindés
la grande surprise et l'efficacité d'un
drone turc déjà bien connu et qui n'est
pas très cher le bayraktar db2 et la
majorité des choses qui volent sous des
drones notamment les drones le scrap
électives et 2 les bayraktar d'origine
turque qui a priori ont une très grande
efficacité et que les russes n'arrivent
pas toujours à identifier et donc avec
les ukrainiens ne tarissent pas d'éloges
pour le drone turc
[Applaudissements]
tout comme pour le missile antichar
suédois fournies par les britanniques le
n la
façon des missiles sont tirés depuis
l'épaule et ça contre les hélicoptères
russes contre les à grand chose quand
ils seront une volée en basse altitude
ça évidemment ça fait énormément mal
les américains ou promis une centaine de
missiles switchblade petit léger moins
de 3 kg il s'ouvre en vol comme un canif
d'où le nom et il est extrêmement
prometteur
parce que ces petits drones switchblade
on ne peut pas les intercepter ni aux
radars ni en infrarouge donc les rejoins
totalement vulnérable face à ces
systèmes qui vont être livrés dans les
prochains jours sur le terrain
réellement l'arrivée de switch blesse à
peu transformé la capacité offensive de
l'armée ukrainienne c'est une sorte de
drones missiles très précis kamikaze car
il se détruit sur sa cible il est tenu
encore assez secret ces armes qui sont
en train de changer l'art de la guerre
ont des effets dévastateurs pour les
russes si on sait que les russes ont
perdu quasiment 2000 blindés on peut se
dire qu'il ya au moins 8000 à 10000
morts du côté russe et ensuite on a
toujours deux à trois fois plus de
blessés que ce qu'on a d'abord essayé
donc certainement 30 à 40000 personnes
qui sont incapables de combattre
aujourd'hui sans compter à ce qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui enfermées dans
certaines pages vous savez pas encore
vers nicolas il ya une contre offre
ainsi l'ukraine elle qui a certainement
bloqué des milliers de russes qui sont
aujourd'hui totalement encerclée donc au
total on estime qu'il ya au moins un
quart de l'armée russe qui est bas prise
mortes ou inaptes au combat
malgré ces pertes mais à cause de la
puissance de son armée la russie
pourrait encore gagner la guerre mais
pas la guerre qu'elle avait prévu jean
michel leprince radio-canada moria